everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm today we're going to be
looking at the queen's gambit opening in
the queen's game it's probably the most
popular gambit out there that most
people play it's played at the top level
quite a bit and one of the reasons for
that is it's not really a true gambit on
the second move white gives up a piece
but can easily get that back black tries
to hold on to that it's actually going
to be in a world of hurt so today we're
going to be looking at a lot of
different variations for the queen's
gambit we're going to look at what
happens if black tries to hold on to it
and some of the main lines that black
has and how to attack those we're going
to be going over a lot of key concepts a
lot of things to always keep in the back
your mind when you're playing the
queen's gambit so hopefully this is
helpful and let's get into it starts out
with pawn to d4 black responds pawn d5
and immediately black plays pawn to c4
now this does a couple thing one it goes
straight to the center and starts an
attack obviously with the Queens gambit
you are trying to take control the
center right away and no better way to
do that than to challenge this pawn on
d5 if any reason this pawn leaves black
or white excuse me white can just come
here to e4 and have great control of the
center with both pawns in the center
real quick we're going to go over what
happens if black tries to take and hold
on to it so black can take and we'll go
over some various lines here in a minute
white can easily just come with a simple
move pawn to e3 now this sets up for a
bishop to just go ahead and take back
this piece and this pawn is nicely
placed it's defending this pawn on d4
getting ready for this attack on c4 now
if black decides he wants to hold on to
it let's say he comes down with this
pawn to b5 white can simply respond with
a four attacking this on b5 black can
always take but then after we take this
pawn is still hanging on c4 and it
eventually will fall
now black sometimes will make an error
in the game and will play pawn to c6 and
after white captures black captures
thinking he's adding another defender to
this but now white has a little trap and
it's a devastating move and it's just
simply Queen to f3 on down this rook on
a8 and there's really nothing black can
do to counter that he can't put his
bishop here because it'll be taken all
he can really do to stop this is move
his knight which will be captured and
then he'll usually move his Bishop here
to block the check and his rook is safe
but he's just lost a minor piece Y can
now just retreat and he's got a rook
open on the a file and black is down
a minor piece so he's going to have a
hard time holding on to which is why we
don't consider the Queen's Gambit a true
gambit now taking the pawn at the
beginning is not a bad move at all as we
see here but black usually is not going
to respond trying to defend a lot of
times you will see him simply develop
his pieces and you will see something
like Knight to f6 and then simply white
can come in and capture the piece that
was taken before and we are even up in
material and as you can see this bishop
is nicely placed it's attacking the
weakness on the f7 square we have two
pawns out controlling the center this
pawn is attacking the c5 and the e5
square while this Bishop is holding down
the d5 square so we have great Center
control we have a minor piece out and
two pawns and he has one minor piece so
if you do play the Queens gambit
accepted line you really have a strong
force in the center black can always
come out here challenge or queen he does
have protection from his knight for the
most part you're going to be developing
your Knights eventually this night will
come here and you're going to castle
this is kind of the setup of the Queens
gambit accepted line now we're going to
kind of take a look at the
Queens gambit declined now this is a lot
more common a lot of players now are
playing the Queens gambit declined line
and it normally starts with a move like
e6 this is kind of the most common to
move at top level play and what it does
is if white tries to take on d5 black
can simply come back and he's got great
center control he's holding down this
efore square white can't come to the
center and he's building up a great
defense the one weakness that he has
though is he is closed in his Bishop
from moving and as far as opening theory
you never want to close and your bishops
with your pawns and in any opening you
should always keep notice to that
especially for yourself in your
opponent's a lot of times you will not
notice trapping your bishops and then
later on when you try to activate them
you realize that they are out of you so
black has a weakness here with his
bishop so we're going to later down the
line try to exploit that but for here
Queens gambit line it's basically a lot
of moves trying to control the center so
we are going to put added pressure on
this d5 Square and develop our knight
here to b3 a lot of times black will
respond developing to f6 putting
pressure on the e4 square so he now has
two attackers on the e4 square and we
have one defender and normally here we
want to before we move this pawn we want
to go ahead and get our bishop out of
the way and the whites 4y the light
square bishop is usually it's more
powerful Bishop so we're going to go
ahead and use our dark square Bishop and
and down this night here this will allow
us if we want to move this pawn one we
definitely can build a nice little pawn
structure where our LightSquared Bishop
can move around freely but you
definitely want to get this Bishop out
first now he can always respond he can
do a slab defense and move his pawn up
he can always move his knight out simply
if he does this attacking we're simply
going to add another defender and
develop to f3 it basically becomes a
build up your pieces and then the
fireworks really start going off in the
center white should have the advantage
in black on the Queen's game it really
just tries to build up a solid defense
and not let white get too much momentum
so these are some of the key concepts to
keep a look at later on down the road
I'll analyze some some GM games that
have played some of the matches in the
Queen's Gambit line but hope y'all have
enjoyed this hope y'all have learned a
lot and be sure to watch the other
videos subscribe and check out the
website www.hsn.com